what was that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just in time
hey girl wow you look like a million
eddies
is that so that is not how i feel
i ate what you call a scumbag
and what you think tasty ask the people
below
the parade will soon begin
i adjusted the data from okada i advise
you to examine it yourself
to begin with the malware works
truly much better than i anticipated
our eyes and ears are in the garden
i observe the cctv and i know where the
sniper potions are
they are true you must make each
harmless
before they do the same to me there are
many ways to reach them
the first is nearby he should not be a
problem
the second is worse you will have to
climb
as for the third he hides on the foot
bridge over the street
we are here hanakusama's platform will
stop
here close to the emergency exit we will
use when always done
from these points you will have a clear
view of the parade
but the snipers will see things even
better
if they notice you bang no more thing
if this sounds dangerous consider that
i must need to the float enter through a
window and
meet hanako face to face
the last is what i fear the most
is all this clear are you ready
[Music]
i'm ready question is are you
i formed this plan did i not all the
while ignoring one crucial element
your friend oda oda is a man of honor
he did not dare raise his hand against
me
maybe you're gonna be dropping in on
hanukkah by surprise
you have a point instinct and reflexes
went out at the moment like this
so so i can only hope that i am still
faster than he is
stay safe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i am in position the floors have started
to run
remember to be careful why you will face
arasaka drones
okay good to go then let us begin
you must reach old snipers before
hannah's
appear
[Music]
[Applause]
world's most powerful
new around here
[Applause]
you are close he's almost
[Applause]
these words
[Applause]
[Music]
junkie
[Music]
[Music]
by the green arrow and take the elevator
take the footprint at the top to cross
the street
[Applause]
[Music]
of violence was an
act of violence
[Music]
check yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what they are this is important
oh that's speaking to someone i am
linking you in
we both can listen again
security is
do your damn job
[Music]
understood over and out
it is just as we expected oda is here
i will contact you with any news
i know that bored out ogre try to reach
the maintenance area
you can climb up from there
[Applause]
[Music]
look too stable sure takamura didn't
plan a little whoopsie-daisy for you
[ __ ] almost fell kill me
[Music]
it is
you will have to get down somehow just
be careful
yes just so don't rush
i need
my father
these words
[Music]
[Music]
it was 50 years ago
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it towers more powerful and enduring
than ever before
recently my father fell victim to an
equally
cowardly act of violence
in which we all share our night city is
its witness
listen
[Music]
stay silent silence
is not golden it is the sound of a flame
[Applause]
exchanged
[Music]
it is the sound of a plane extinguished
[Music]
is
[Music]
found just a few feet more and he is
yours
[Music]
it's the shortest route to the next
sniper he positioned himself high
keep you posted
it is
over and out did you hear they know
something
perhaps match we must hurry
hello where are you
i'm engaging
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
um
don't break ranks
[Music]
try to reach the maintenance area you
can climb up from there
[Music]
and if that doesn't work you can use the
foot bridge to your right
watch out for the floor jets unless you
intend to get cooked
i would keep my head low we're being
attacked
you [ __ ] gunk
[Music]
kill or be killed
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i will personally find you
let's shoot the patrols the front bridge
oh
oh
that would be all yes apparently
well done what problem remains
[Music]
she has taken control all the legs
[Music]
and if that doesn't work you can use the
foot bridge to your right
watch out full of launchers unless you
intend to get cooked
i would keep my head alone you're only
making it worse for yourself
i'm out
hello where are you
find you and bury you
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
yes
apparently well done what problem
remains
that is the arasaka nato
she has taken control of all the
networks
you must get rid of her will not be able
to hijack the float otherwise
she hides in an unfinished apartment
building
here to the second sniper's nest okay on
my way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] not good
been on a while time for a break
[ __ ] of course
i warned you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
cool
[Music]
i i managed to
hold up he's breathing
for now please be
show him mercy there should be nothing
standing in your way now
we press forward
you and your [ __ ] sick sense of honor
[Music]
today's your lucky day though
okay preem online and in the system
hanukkah's inside what is you doing
trying to call someone i think
try to listen do not forget to dissolve
[Music]
all systems jammed it's now or never
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] he shot her well now
we're really [ __ ]
knew we couldn't trust him what happened
to keeping him on his leash
we best dealt to the [ __ ] outta here
[Music]
you